i think we just need to be honest with
these conservatives and just be like yes
we want to kill babies there's nothing
wrong with that
you can't just let every baby live
[Music]
like these conservatives they treat
their [ __ ] cattle but better than
they treat their [ __ ] human beings
like if the cows like dying they'll just
put him out of his misery if he's like
an important like [ __ ] [ __ ] up cow
with 17 legs
but like when a human being turns out
like you know like you're gay or
something
you let them live
kill those [ __ ] gay babies
that's how we get them on board
if we if we can find out which babies
are gay will you be on board with
abortions
we have a gaydar for a sonogram monogram
whatever
and find out which ones will vote for
biden
you're saying you want this baby to live
and vote for biden
[ __ ] it you hate america you don't want
to kill this baby
um you know abortion laws
uh you know should we really have laws
telling us who we can and can't kill
whatever happened to freedom
we should be able to decide who dies
um you know i love i love a good
abortion
they've stopped doing the coat hanger
thing i think it's like a
[Music]
this is how i think abortions go down ah
the woman comes in and she's like oh my
god i just had sex and it's like so
stupid i have a baby now this sucks
i'm like okay
hop on the table and then they uh
and then they like put a needle in and
then just put it fill it with like
cyclone b or uh
and the baby it's like a concentration
camp in there
[Music]
you know the shower head has eleven
holes
so even if it has fingers it can't cover
it all up
and then the baby dies
uh and then the girl's like thank you so
much
i'm gonna palazzo down
can we party
and then you know the world goes around
more drinks are bought um
ubers are paid for the economy
functions